hay una función que casi pasa
desapercibida en twitter cada vez que
alguien publica algo en esta red social
la red expone desde que celular se está
publicando el otro día cargado mejor
conocida como la mujer maravilla tuiteó
a sus 2.6 millones de seguidores el
siguiente tweet digan hola a mi nuevo
mail con made se refería al nuevo huawei
10 may prop
un celular que para ella en el vídeo que
estaba expuesto en este tweet en el
mejor del mundo s estaba enamorada de la
cámara de la velocidad de la estética
del celular y eso recomiendo este
celular a sus seguidores se dice
claramente que está utilizando este
celular damas y caballeros les cuento
que este tweet fue realizado desde un
iphone desde un iphone tal vez se dan
cuenta que hay algo malo aquí les
explico gal no puede decir que está
utilizando un huawei no puedes
recomendarlo y estar utilizando un like
esto es deshonesto para cualquier ser
humano pero más aún para gal alguien
como ella que le siguen tanta gente pero
porque el gal gadot haría algo así de
deshonesto no tiene sentido pero tal vez
si con estas cifras para que tengan una
idea 5.78 dólares está ganando cada
empresa por cada dólar que invierte en
marketing o influencers de hecho 49 por
ciento de las personas que compran algo
en internet dicen que dependen de la
recomendación de una influencia y 4 de
cada 10 personas compran algo luego de
verlo en alguna red social
así que claramente hay una influencia
muy fuerte las empresas saben que para
acceder a la audiencia de una influencia
hay que pagar un fin un costo financiero
y lamentablemente la mayoría de
influencia es poco les importa el
prestigio el impacto ambiental a la hora
de investigar si es que esta empresa
está haciendo bien las cosas nada más
los influences recomendaron un producto
si es que la empresa está dispuesta a
pagar un excelente ejemplo que les puedo
dar es el fire festival pensemos en una
playa paradisíaca supermodelos comida
gourmet ilimitada una fiesta de tres
días sin reglas en una playa
completamente aislada de las de la
sociedad es lo que se promocionó en las
redes sociales de los influencias de
moda recomendaron este festival y en
cuestión de horas se terminaron el 100%
de las entradas
de hecho las más costosas llegaron
a costar 50 mil dólares imagínense 50
mil dólares por una entrada a un
festival una locura qué es lo que pasa
cuando el 98% de marketing se te va en
marketing o influencias
llegó la mañana del evento y
misteriosamente algunas bandas se
empezaron a cancelar su asistencia
dijeron que no existía garantía para que
se dé el concierto como estaba
estipulado en el contrato la gente igual
series lo viajo al evento pocos fueron
los minutos que pasaron para darse
cuenta que el festival soñado se
convertiría en una pesadilla nadie le
recibió en el aeropuerto de hecho les
empezaron a acomodar en las suites de
lujo que eran unas carpas mal armadas
con cero seguridad no existían baños no
existía aire acondicionado era un
infierno de hecho cuando les empezaron a
pasar la comida gourmet era una tarrina
con una lechuga mojada mal parqueada en
el pan algo terrible en serio terrible
fueron horas las que pasaron para que
esto se convierta en una crisis
sanitaria la gente ni siquiera podía
salir de la isla
kim kardashian mejor conocida como una
de las supermodelos norteamericanas más
famosas del momento una gurú
el marketing una empresaria muy conocida
solo en instagram tiene 206 millones de
seguidores alrededor de esta red social
les cuento que el otro día se alió con
dic leyes es una droga que promete
reducir los estragos de los mareos
matutinos que son síntomas bastante
comunes en mujeres embarazadas justo en
esta época kim estaba embarazada y ella
le dice a su audiencia que esta fue una
de las pocas cosas una de las pocas
drogas que le ayudó a ella para lidiar
con los síntomas de su embarazo pocos
minutos luego de que ella comparte en
instagram una foto con la droga sale
live idea que es la food and drugs
administration
la entidad que regula las farmacéuticas
en eeuu a decir que lo que ella hizo es
ilegal no se puede recomendar una droga
sin exponer claramente cuáles son los
efectos adversos
pocas fueron las mujeres que empezaron a
sentir estos estragos y de una grande se
salvó a kim al no exponer esto en
primera instancia le tocó borrar su
publicación y publicar una con un copy
mucho más largo en el cual se exponía
claramente cuáles son estos estragos
hace cinco años estaba conversando con
unos amigos y nos dimos cuenta que todo
el contenido que estábamos consumiendo
era de eeuu o de mexico y nos
preguntamos qué ridículo es el hecho de
que estamos consumiendo el contenido de
los vecinos cuando vivimos en un país
tan diverso hablando de gastronomía y
turismo porque nadie está haciendo
contenido de calidad en el país que está
pasando hay alguna traba para impedir
esto nuestra respuesta fue nada así que
en vez de esperar que alguien más lo
haga
creamos vox populi un canal que buscaba
documentar con una altísima calidad lo
mejor en gastronomía y turismo del país
así que trabajamos muy duro durante seis
meses con esta meta
y tratar de documentar lo mejor de este
país hasta que un día nos llamó a un
restaurante y nos dijo chicos nos
encanta su programa queremos ser parte
de él cuánto nos cuesta cuánto nos vale
colgamos y de la emoción empezamos una
reunión para debatir cuánto cobramos era
nuestro primer trabajo cobrado así que
conversamos con el restaurante y
decidimos cobrarle 150 dólares nos
agendamos una cita para documentar esta
experiencia gastronómica
y ahí es cuando se puso de color hormiga
todo les cuento el lugar era feo había
mucho frío se notaba que no había pisado
ese restaurante un alma en mucho tiempo
la frescura de los alimentos era dudosa
tanto el origen como la calidad era
dudosa de estos productos la comida fue
fea pero imagínense todo el equipo de la
cocina viendo a sus ojos y esperando que
se recomienda este producto nosotros
habíamos hecho una promesa y vamos a
recomendar su restaurante por 150
dólares editamos el vídeo lo publicamos
y a nuestros seguidores les gustó
misteriosamente pasó algo bonito en esa
época que nos sirvió como un jalón de
orejas les cuento aquí vamos a hacer
alguna diligencia en el centro comercial
y detrás nuestro escuchábamos
nos damos la vuelta y a veces nos pedían
una foto y nos decían chicos nos encanta
lo que están haciendo les admiramos
muchísimo sigue adelante son unos cracks
nosotros obviamente sentimos que pagamos
en algún nivel a estos seguidores
sin embargo eso cambia después y
mejoramos ya les cuento ahora creo que
la influencia es clara lamentablemente
no todos los de influencias lo hacen
bien qué pasa cuando el escenario es
distinto
recordemos que el 60% de las compras en
internet son realizadas por la
influencia de alguien más sea por un
vídeo o sea por un blog ya que pasa con
el influencer es responsable de su
influencia es responsable de sus actos
de sus recomendaciones investiga
activamente cuál es el prestigio el
impacto ambiental de las marcas qué pasa
cuando un influencer reconoce el poder
que tiene su influencia bueno pasan
cosas fantásticas les cuento que en
indonesia el 37% de la población no
quiere vacunarse dicen que no creen en
la vacuna así de simple así que el
gobierno de indonesia le tocó inventarse
alguna estrategia para cambiar esta
opinión pública así que la segunda
persona que se va cuando en indonesia
fue
ahmad es una influencia de instagram que
cuenta con 50 millones de seguidores en
mixta
rap y comparte una foto en su instagram
diciendo no le tengan miedo a las
vacunas mientras de él se vacunaba
decenas de miles de personas empezaron a
vacunarse luego de ver este post
diciendo me voy a vacunar sólo porque
rap y lo hizo
fantástico márquez brown link es un
techno web con 14 millones de seguidores
en youtube
márquez se dedica a hacer reviews un
boxing de dispositivos tecnológicos
básicamente se dedica a decir si un
dispositivo tecnológico vale la pena o
no comprarlo así que en una de sus
últimas entrevistas márquez cuenta que
diariamente recibe unos 100 correos al
día en estos correos hay una propuesta
económica bastante atractiva de empresas
muy reconocidas a nivel mundial en el
área tecnológica las empresas le dicen
márquez
estamos dispuestos a pagarte lo que sea
porque digas que nuestro siguiente
laptop celular tablet van a ser los
mejores
pero márquez es muy inteligente él sabe
que la gente que le ve
independientemente si le pagan o no él
va a decir la verdad este poder esta
sinceridad y esta transparencia le ha
puesto en un lugar que pocas personas
han estado es una referencia verdadera
en el mundo de la tecnología ahora se
están preguntando cómo ganar dinero
márquez no sólo están los anuncios de
youtube sino que márquez activamente da
asesoría a las empresas públicamente
muchas empresas de tecnología han
declarado que les satisface
acatar las recomendaciones y las
críticas de márquez porque él muestra o
él representa a 14 millones de personas
entonces márquez no sólo influencia en
sus seguidores sino también en las
empresas
márquez es el ejemplo de un verdadero
influencia
se cuelan de vox populi bueno como les
dije mejoramos cambiamos
hicimos caso a lo que era la definición
de nuestro nombre en primer lugar vox
populi significa la voz del pueblo así
que conjuntamente con nuestra audiencia
creamos un segmento que se llama
mundialito cogemos 16 marcas de las más
conocidas en el momento y las comparamos
directamente pueden ser marcas de licor
de galletas de snacks de sangin
lo que sea y comparamos activamente
cosas como su calidad cantidad precio
sabor etcétera
algo interesante es que la opinión de
nuestros seguidores es determinante para
decidir quién pasa a la final y cuál se
corona como el mejor producto en una
categoría nos dimos cuenta que si la
gente iba a dedicarse a ver horas y
horas los vídeos de vox populi tenía que
ser sustentable teníamos que ser
sinceros y teníamos que hacerles
partícipes de esta comunidad que
estábamos creando
ahora como se darán cuenta la influencia
real está presente en la vida de cada
uno de nosotros ahora cómo saber si una
influencia es verdadero está diciendo la
verdad no sé sincero esta es una mala
noticia no se puede saber es imposible
lamentablemente no existe un filtro que
podamos revisar pero se pueden tomar
algunas acciones algunas recomendaciones
para acercarnos hacia lo que realmente
necesitamos como consumidores una de
ellas es reconocer la diferencia entre
un influencer y un famoso un famoso es
aquella persona que le sigue mucha gente
porque es chistoso porque es un buen
actor porque es agraciado físicamente
porque tiene mucho dinero porque estuvo
en algún escándalo que hizo llamar la
atención pero un influencers es aquel
experto que de acuerdo a sus estudios de
acuerdo a su recorrido a sus proyectos
ha logrado documentar todo esto y le ha
puesto en una posición en la sociedad
que su voz
una opinión que nos puede mejorar la
vida esto es un verdadero influencia
no le podemos pedir consejos de
maquillaje a cristiano ronaldo cristiano
ronaldo es una influencia de fútbol no
de maquillaje otra cosa que podemos
hacer es reconocer que el boca a boca es
digital sigue siendo muy poderoso pero
ahora está en otro lado si investigamos
sobre un producto y nos topamos con que
hay mil vídeos recomendando este
producto de nada sirve que sea del canal
de youtube de la marca la marca siempre
va a hablar maravillas de sus productos
es indispensable encontrar referencias
ajenas a las del producto ver blogs
escritos vídeos de otros canales podemos
ir a nuestra tienda favorita y revisar
los reviews mínimo es recomendable
encontrar tres fuentes ajenas que
recomienden un producto y si hay alguna
científica aún mejor
y la última es un examen de
autoconciencia es necesario depurar
nuestras redes si es que tenemos de una
a dos horas al día para revisar nuestras
redes sociales en serio creen que
podemos estar pendiente de lo que
publican 500 personas es imposible yo
seguía a 5 mil personas ahora sigo a 200
y mi meta es seguir a 50 constantemente
debemos preguntarnos si a quién estamos
siguiendo nos sirve como una opinión
proactiva que nos está ayudando de
alguna forma en nuestra vida nos ayuda a
comprar mejor nos alegra el día es
indispensable reconocer quién está
haciendo esto en nuestra vida
los influencers siempre serán una
vitrina para los productos que
recomendarán los productos que están
aliados a las marcas de su interés
al final del lledó emitirá una opinión
su opinión nosotros tenemos que
descifrar si esta opinión aplica a
nuestra vida
ser escéptico es indispensable en estos
tiempos
[Aplausos]